in other news nine current or former
minneapolis police officers have now
testified against their former colleague
that's derek chovin in his murder trial
prosecutors called four officers to the
stand yesterday including
a use of force expert from the los
angeles police department as jamie yukas
reports
all four all four of them criticize a
fired officer's treatment
of george floyd my opinion was that the
force was excessive
los angeles police sergeant jody steiger
has trained nearly 3
000 police officers in use of force
tactics
they should have slowed down or stopped
their forces steiger's testimony
followed more than half a dozen
minneapolis police officers
including lieutenant johnny mercel the
department's own use of force instructor
chauvin attended his training class in
2018.
is this an mpd trained neck restraint
no sir
it ever been not to my neck restraint no
sir
officer nicole mckenzie the medical
coordinator for the minneapolis police
department
was asked about this moment you're doing
fine you're talking fine just because
they're
speaking doesn't mean they're breathing
adequately but the defense asked
mackenzie if the crowd could have
distracted chauvin
a central point in their case it's very
difficult to focus on
that patient while there's other things
around you if you
don't feel safe around you ben crump one
of the floyd family attorneys
said he has never seen so many officers
testify against another
it is our hope that that will become the
norm
when police see things that are wrong or
violate policy that they will tell the
truth thank you we love you all
floyd's brother rodney was at a midday
prayer service outside the courthouse
everyone wants justice this is all she's
ethnicities
that's responding and replying and
reaching out to us saying they feel our
pain
today that lapd expert will be back on
the stand and likely to face an
aggressive cross-examination
while mckenzie was called by the
prosecution the defense said that it
intends to call her back
about drug use as part of its case tony
we'll be following along jamie thank you
very much